this is the coolest
in the whole world by the way we have a
very special guest today
we are part of the 3d concept team that
works at the mandalorian season one and
two
how many people work on this it was one
person
wow as best as you can start to finish
how do you make this shot
thanks to raycon for sponsoring today's
episode stick around to the end to find
out how you can get 15
off your pair of premium wireless
earbuds hey what's up everyone welcome
back to another episode of visual
effects artists react
i'm very excited because we have a very
special guest today felix george is on
the couch with us today
can you tell us about your background i
am the ceo and creative director happy
mushroom our current focus is in virtual
collection for environmental design
we are part of the 3d concept team that
works in pre-production designing the
mandalorian season one and two
i think traditionally people think of
virtual reduction and they think of
mocap suits
but we think of environments we think of
lighting we think of photorealistic
assets
maybe you would just even sum it up as
simply like using game engines
for your final image i'm really excited
to hear all your insights
so let's get started
so the big predecessor john favreau
directed to the mandalorian was the
jungle book and it has a lot of the same
technology
minus the actual volume stage i was
heading the environment team for all the
pre-production on this and we had a team
of 12 people
12 environment artists and we were using
unity still
okay so this is a unity project one of
the major similarities
with jungle book and the mandalorian is
that we had
lighters lighting environments with the
dp
months prior to the shoot so he was
actually involved
with lighting all the sets so by the
time they get to the shoot and he has to
influence the shoot and how it has to be
lit he already had all his information
this was a complicated scene because
they wanted him to be able to react to
the bear
i do remember seeing a behind the scenes
shot of this where mowgli was like
sitting on something and john favreau
was actually in the water interacting
with them
but then it is all replaced also notice
how mowgli is actually sitting
on a real bear prop with that wet fur so
that you don't have to really worry
about that
that contact interaction going on
between mowgli's skin
and the real fur there have you guys
seen the
other mowgli movie oh the andy circus
one
the pack needs you mowgli
this one came out shortly it kind of
came out around this yeah it was very
close
i speak for the gun we have one
god this one the eyes though kill me in
this one
they're human eyes on animals oh
what is going on there that is so weird
you're right
it is it's like it doesn't matter how
good everything looks because the eyes
are like hard to look away
it's because i think the animals are
actual like motion captured
performances from people so i think
they're trying to replicate the emotion
behind the eyes
in these animals that's the the eternal
problem with trying to do animals that
emote right you gotta like find the
balance between
being able to convey emotion that humans
understand aka like facial emotions and
whatnot
but also still maintain the fact that
it's an animal that was a problem that
they had on
the lion king movie that john favreau
did they they tried to like give these
animals emotion but also
never depart too far from the fact that
they are still animals
i think jungle book did a better job
than both of them jungle book was
not trying to be super hyper realistic
with the faces i mean it was
photorealistic
with everything else but they had a
level of emotion that i enjoyed
it's very hard to fake light and shadow
and so everything became about using
panels of leds to project lights
[Music]
so the eventuality of that workflow
manifests in the mandalorian and we've
talked about mandalorian before
awesome show awesome technology behind
it i feel like
we get caught up in the fact that
because you have all these high quality
screens actually emitting the proper
light is like the perfect blend of what
it would actually look like
i hadn't really considered the
collaboration side of things
before even production begins you know
on these projects we're doing 3d
concepts
we're doing all the 3d concepts in
unreal with all the key creatives and
then we pass that over to the ilm
team but by the time we passed it over
all the tools that they would use in
real life were there so like the
director had all his lenses
the dp had his actual lights that he
would use in real life
replicated in unreal the production
designer had
virtual location scouts normally when
you go scout a film location
you'll see like a small crowd of people
like a director and a producer and maybe
a dp
they're all walking around looking at
stuff taking pictures but now
with virtual production you can do that
with vr
headsets and that's crazy we're working
directly with
all of them you're making the movie
before you make the movie yeah and then
by the time you get to making the movie
and you're already on production you you
can still change it you're telling me
you design the sets
before you film it's like wait a second
hold on that's how you're supposed to do
it you design the props you design the
sets
and then you film with them versus going
oh
uh look we don't have a costume figured
out just put these polka dots on your
chest
and dance on the green screen and we'll
figure out
what the story is like why you're there
later
when i first watched this episode and i
saw this room i was just like it's a set
i heard about the volume and i was like
oh each time they're on like a crazy
sci-fi mountain
it's like the volume because you know
you can't recreate that but i look at
this and it's like yeah you can
build a set that looks like that so i
didn't think a single thing of it and
then someone was like no that's on one
of those stages too i'm like
what i was like you can make that scene
in unreal
engine this is the way this is the way
so like
can you just as best as you can start to
finish
how do you make the shot the first thing
that happens is obviously we have a
kickoff meeting and the kickoff meeting
is going to have the concept art
the idea the mood we collaborate on
these worlds together
the set decorator the production
designer the vfx supervisor and as we're
doing layout
the set decorator is building those
crates in a workshop
in a workshop with their hands with
their hands yeah okay
yeah so they're they're going they're
building stuff physically and we're over
here
building things virtually so they're
like they're building these
props and then kind of the expectation
is cool you'll bring them
to the set and put them on the floor but
you're like
hey we want to reference them in our
virtual set first
so you photo scan them bring them into
the virtual set
and then sometimes when you actually hit
photography
the real boxes never even make it in oh
yes sometimes they just stay in the
virtual world and then you have the fact
that because
it's unreal and especially with unreal
engine 5 hopefully this gets even bigger
on the day if the dp goes the box that
crate in the back that red crate is
distracting it maybe make it a great
crate
he still has that call he can still do
that i feel like that's the magic of
shooting on a volume because you get to
make those informed
decisions of like all right now that i'm
actually here looking at it i've kind of
changed my mind i want to lower the
camera a little bit that gives a better
angle
i wouldn't have known that until i was
here looking at it on set
which you would normally do on a real
set but when you're having to do
a green screen set you don't have that
there too informative
[Music]
so he gets he gets in a fight here right
like he gets jumped
one of the major things that they wanted
to do was the reflection of the guy
jumping over his helmet what wait wait
yeah again there it is again what wait
how the heck do you do that we had to do
a lot of work
in pre-production to see where on the
helmet it was going to happen and make
sure that the story beat was going to
come out appropriately
it's beautiful when you see things like
this just because it's real
like the reflection is real that helmet
that shot
would be so expensive
so the dirt's real on the ground we got
some mud yes but then the rocks
none of the rocks are real nothing so
the first the
first layer of rocks that is on set the
screen is elevated from the ground so
they put stuff there to hide the
the screen transition there's a scene
now the stuff that we have
in the foreground those were modeled by
a 3d modeler
and then they were remodeled by a
physical modeler a
model maker on set and then they may
have even been scanned and brought back
into unreal
gotcha so that we can match his look
we're basically getting as close as
possible to the final product the goal
here is to be able to hit record on the
camera
and not have to do anything with that
footage after the fact yes
on a special effects film
were the leds able to do everything or
did you need extra lights
absolutely need extra lights a dp could
use all of his traditional lighting
he'll just have to be more mindful of
how it affects the screen
let's say he wanted to put a big light
over here shooting this way
would you then have to go in and put
that light in the same position in
unreal in the virtual set
yeah there's a couple night time scenes
where there's some moonlight
they use these channel balls gigantic
right you know and so
we china recreated those china moons
[Laughter]
we are placing them exactly where they
would be in real life
okay that way they could go and mimic
exactly that on the day
definitely speaks to that concept of
like all right let's conform these
elements here it's like yes we're
filming a movie that has a lot of cg
but that doesn't mean we have to
disregard all the best practices
for capturing images that we've worked
on and created over the last 100 years
of filmmaking
definition of virtual production right
there there you go bam that's what i've
heard today
this is the coolest in the whole world
by the way this is the coolest
[Music]
so now it's time for the subscribe push
wait we're skipping subscribe day
it's not like leg day yeah we can skip
this thing we don't need to say
subscribe
every video
so we'd like to take a look at a piece
from ian hubert he's a good friend of
ours and happens to be a blender
god a project he's been working on for
three years
has just come out and it's brilliant
let's take a look
this is one of the coolest shots in
cinema history dude we're hyping this up
it really is incredible
look at this oh that's this is all siege
nothing is real i mean she's real she
except for her she's real
like good god the light matching that
lighting
she looks phenomenal and don't forget
she hasn't left the platform that she
was standing on the entire time
this is all done on one tiny stage when
she walks out of the apartment there's
already a dude standing off to her left
ready to serve her food how many people
work on this it was basically just him
and his girlfriend is the lead actor
yeah wow i know it's funny it's like you
watch
content like this and you're like oh it
took like two years to make it it's like
that's cool it's like
it was one person yeah not 200.
i just don't i don't get it i mean i've
seen projects that take three years that
aren't even close to this
we have movies that have hundreds of
people that take five years
i think the biggest thing and why this
feels real and why ian's work
works so well is his huge use of
photo scans and photograph based
textures and basically rather than
inventing a model from scratch he uses
photos first
and then turns those photos into models
using that original image
as its base texture so everything we're
seeing here is photographically
based at its core
here with this shot of the robot we're
following the robot floating down
all cg all cg all cg and then
we got a live action plate there in the
background and we're moving up to it and
he's managed to transition
flawlessly because he's using a
combination of the actual handheld
movement of him
walking up and blending that with his
own extra camera movement to make it
even bigger
watching this just gets me jazzed up
that's why you see how amped we are
right now is because
his stuff is that good it's just
freaking spectacular
ian actually kind of got famous off of
these short little
he calls them lazy tutorials they're one
minute long and it's basically just
ian being charismatic teaching people
how to use blender in a very bite-sized
way and it's incredibly entertaining
oh wait peter peter come here is that
peter
just in time peter so obviously you've
seen this piece right
i've seen this piece it came out two
days ago i've seen it like five times
already that's awesome this is my third
time watching it as well
no competition or anything but we're
gonna give ian a call and he's gonna
come in
and give us some insights on how he made
it i just sent this video to all my
friends today
like you need to watch this this is
amazing hey
what's up ian yeah what up ian how's it
going oh it's going good
you guys are all on the couch yeah we
are how are you feeling
oh man it feels so good to finally have
that thing out there
i'm excited to talk about it it's been
the only thing kind of i've had going
for a few years now
you obviously have been putting out a
lot of youtube videos over the last few
years
but what would you say was the
percentage of time on a weekly basis
that you would spend on this film versus
other stuff
probably on average four hours a day for
years
it's hard to know because i flowed a lot
of my work making this
into tutorials and assets and breakdowns
which i go and i put on like the patreon
or youtube or something
the making of the thing kind of helped
me keep making it
and so i lost all track of time and just
kind of went into a crazy work zone what
would you say was the most challenging
aspect of making this entire film
i mean the practical stuff for sure i
only do a shoot every
six months to a year or so and so every
single time it's like all right what can
we shoot in like an hour
when it comes to filming there's a lot
to be said for building up a headspace
and a momentum
it was a really organic process but
again very very inefficient
the guy who runs the market who lives
underground
oh hello are you full merchant nine
three four three eight
two seven one one seven three nine what
the heck is going on with the guy's
eyeball is that
real or is that cg well it's uh it's a
real head
we wrapped it in elmer's glue and toilet
paper trying to do like the rotting
flesh thing
it didn't work very well so it's a real
head yeah that's my friend andy
duprowski
he's a lot okay but we just filmed him
like
moving his eyeball around and i froze
the rest of the frame so it's just the
one eyeball looking at like the phoneme
chart
it was like the craziest looking most
disturbing thing
what's next like what are your future
visions for
where this project can go is there an
episode two in the works
the biggest goal is figure out how to do
whatever i can to make it take less than
three years
because if my complete output is like 45
minutes per decade
i wanted to make more than that i'm
really trying to figure out whether it's
you know real-time virtual production
stuff or uh
just a lot more emphasis on practical
sets a way to try to keep that same
level of world building but without
having to spend years
making it all in in post virtual
production is the way because then you
control the whole vision
so now the question is when are you
gonna come visit us so that you could be
sitting here on the couch as well
as soon as possible it's it's so
impressive and beautiful
thanks for making it man and thanks for
sharing it with everyone thanks for
thanks for having me on good good to see
you guys take care man
see you peace
guys i've got the beat in my head
because today's episode sponsor is
raycon earbuds one of my favorite
sponsors on this channel
they are effin champions raycons have
all of the bells and whistles that you
would expect from any other premium
wireless audio solution they have six
hours of play time they have a
rechargeable carrying case that you can
easily slide into your pocket
and take with you and recharge your
earbuds when you're on the go
they have more bass i think they have a
better more compact design that's
sleeker
it's more stylish and of course it
creates a nice
noise isolating fit whenever you're
wearing them they have a variety of fun
colors and patterns maybe your favorite
color is red
okay well guess what they got red ones
pretty sweet and they do all of this
without any dangling stems or wires this
is because
they focus on the customer experience
first from start to finish so anyways if
you guys are interested head on over to
buy raycon.com
corridor crew and you can get 15 off
your purchase
they're a great earbud to include in
your daily routine and i'm super glad
that they continually sponsor this show
just wanted to let you guys know
once again don't go out and buy them on
your own use the link in the description
below and get that 15
off and um anyways tell your friends
i don't know watch the rest of the
episode i don't know i don't know where
we go from here
nick's gonna make that call i don't i
don't i don't make those kind of calls
it's
above my pay grade but anyways well
see you later felix thank you so much
for coming on man i really appreciate it
it was fun having you here
this was super fun where can we find
more information about your company
if you'd like to learn more just go to
happymushroom.com that's it
all right easy super easy thank you for
sharing these stories
and like your insight and how all this
stuff is being put together because
we're all super jazzed about it too guys
thank you for having me
oh also thank you for the premiere
tickets to the next star wars film i
really appreciate that totally i'll let
you know
oh my god